what is up youtube welcome back to my
channel and this week we have
amanda hey i think i'm a permanent
feature now yeah
do people have decided honestly last
week the most popular video of the whole
week
was the video that i did with amanda the
week before the most popular video of
the week was the
one that i did with amanda um so i think
the people have spoken so
the plan is what's the plan the plan is
just to chat about
different things that we're going to be
doing so i mean we're going to talk
about the week
yeah no i mean the plan moving forward
with this oh
with the podcast okay and the plan is
that every week um on a saturday
it will be the samuel and randa's shirt
we haven't decided what to call it yet
yet so we did ask last week people to
come up with ideas but not many people
did there's a few that did so thank you
to those who did so saturday
7 00 p.m you're going to be having an
update from myself and amanda and we're
going to be talking about a little bit
about property
about business mindset what we're doing
in the week
uh lifestyle yeah all things whatever
whatever so well what have we been up to
this week what i mean what's what's your
week consisted of
my week's been good it's been um nice
spending time outdoors with the kids
yeah the weather's been good
so one of the things that we did the
kids love the bear hunt
so you're gonna make me look really bad
now the kids love the bear hunt so me
and samuel thought it'd be a really good
idea check i just hope when you say the
kids love the bare hands
yeah unless people who are watching this
have also got young kids
no idea what the bear hunter yeah the
bear hunt okay it's this um it's a song
that you sing
we're going on a bear hunt you're gonna
catch a big one
okay and then you go through the woods
or wherever and then they find
this bear but when the kids in the
little well they usually play
outside themselves so we thought if we
get an actual
bear then they would love that so samuel
got a bear suit like not just a bear
suit it was like a
full on yeah proper what what did they
call them those
uh mazda i don't know i don't know i
remember but mascot yeah
mascot bear outfit yeah with the sole
purpose of
entertaining uh kids yep exactly so the
idea was
the kids would go outside and play and
then this bear would just appear but
it's a friendly bed
it's a very friendly bear it looks like
ted if you've ever watched ted the movie
it looks like that
so um i sent the kids outside to play
and then samuel appeared to them but it
went horribly
wrong they didn't react how we thought
they would
and they just like started crying went
and hid
it was a fight or flight situation they
hid behind some bushes together
and were just like they were silent
actually they were saying they weren't
hiding just for fun they weren't behind
they were actually they were petrified
devastated yeah
like i couldn't see that clearly because
i was in this big suit i'm just standing
there
as this big full-on bear and it's
it was quite a convincing bear it was
yeah i guess
obviously it was a friendly bear okay it
was like a
kiddie movie type bear yeah i'm not
looking for them
they were like literally they hid into a
bush
and they were silent they were slightly
silent and hiding i was quite impressed
with how they
operate because i thought that they
would i initially thought they were just
going to be excited come on
oh my gosh no no they weren't they were
like petrified they were petrified
yeah that kind of went wrong and then
now
but they were so petrified though we
needed to finish the story yeah go on
because i then thought okay
that they're hiding in the bush i didn't
want to go over
to them because that might scare them
more yeah so i kind of just like
went back went back to house and said i
don't think they like bear amanda yeah
uh what do you think we should do
mandy went out and they were crying
they ran out from where they were hiding
and they were just like the brook down
crying like yeah and then after that
they wouldn't leave the house alone
yeah yeah so now the weather's so good
and i'm like oh come on go outside and
usually just play in the back garden
so i felt awkward so what did we do to
resolve that problem
what do we do no what did we do i don't
remember
oh yeah i forgot
okay so then samuel then introduced the
bear
like and showed them that it was just a
suit and you know that it's a friendly
bear and then we went out you dressed up
as the bear
and then i was like come on let's give
the bear a cuddle then we cuddled the
bear and stuff so now
well i had an idea that was amanda beats
up the bear
yeah i thought imagine if i go out and
then the kid's like oh my gosh the bear
and then amanda comes out and beats the
bear up and stomps on the bear and then
the kids are like yeah
but then amanda said that would be a
terrible idea
because it would encourage violence
exactly and
i thought yeah you're probably right i
spoke to my mum about the idea and she
said that was an absolutely awful idea
so instead instead uh yeah i just had to
come into the office and i came to the
office
and i said look and i showed them the
glove of the bear
this is a suit it's pretend it's put out
and then i brought out the bare head
just the just the bare head on its own
with me holding it was enough to make
luke be like
ah i like screaming i actually like
peek-a-boo
with the bear it's all okay and then
finally
okay they're okay so now they are just
about at a level now
where they can leave the house without
fearing the bear yeah
yeah so that's what you've been up to
that's what i've been up to enjoying the
weather with the kids meanwhile i've
been getting verified on youtube
oh i'm so glad that when that happened
because i mean i've been on youtube now
by the way massive thank you to
everybody that watches the channel
because it was actually
uh two days ago now we have the six year
anniversary
of when i created my youtube channel so
good i'm so proud of you which means
that
which means that when we first met i
didn't have the youtube channel
no so when me and amanda met i wasn't a
millionaire
i was financially free i had a property
portfolio about 12 houses
uh maybe a few more than that but
approximately but there were cash
flowing
okay i was making decent money but i was
not by no stretch of the imagination was
i millionaire
and i had no youtube channel so i kind
of documented my way
to becoming a millionaire on youtube um
my first youtube videos were
you probably remember my first remember
my phone they were hand holding so you
were deal packaging
and then one of the things that you used
to do was if someone bought a property
off you you then
go out with them actually you'd go out
with them view lots of different
properties and then they would then
decide which one they wanted
yeah he used to document all of that
basically i was dealing packaging yeah
but i was
bespoke offering yeah off service where
and when you sell a deal to somebody
they'll then want to see the deal
so i just say look come on out look at
the deal i'll show you the house
i'll introduce you to my power team i'll
show you around we'll spend a few hours
together
that process i thought you know what
i'll start filming that process
and putting it on youtube and then that
way i'll be able to show people
you know my clients that they're happy
my investors and it might be able to get
more investors so i can sell more deals
that's why i set the youtube channel up
initially and then it just kind of grew
and then we set the training company up
yeah um
only five years ago so about a year
after that was the training company up
um so yeah crazy and also the same do
you know what this stuff this is really
constant because the same day that we
celebrated the six year youtube
anniversary not that we did a big
celebration for it
i got a little message notification yeah
on youtube congratulations this is
you know six six years today but that
same day was the same day
of my 1000th upload on youtube really
oh my god is that the loss of
celebration oh my gosh it's so good
but the reason i'm so happy about the
verification and all the variation is
it's not a big deal
it just means that you've got a tick
next to your name you know and some
people like they long for the
um for the approval of the youtube gods
that say you are
very fine you know like i remember i had
some friends that were teasing me um
because i'm not yet instagram verified
and people were saying oh you've not
even got a blue chick
um i think liv was joking about it and i
was like
i'm not worthy of mark zuckerberg's blue
chick like who cares
it's not really a big deal however on
youtube it is a big deal because
what was happening on youtube on youtube
i don't know if you've noticed but
whenever he uploads a video someone has
a picture
the same one that you have on your
youtube profile and then they pretend to
be samuel but
it's really bad because then they'll say
like contact me on whatsapp they'll put
a number
and that they're basically scammers and
you know it's really really bad because
it looks like it's him commenting and
it's not yeah so basically if i
if i post a video and then you comment
and go i'll sing a great video or maybe
not maybe you say send me a terrible
video
whatever you comment this this fake
person will comment under me
but the thing is you people might people
might think why don't you just block
that song why don't you deal with it
hundreds and hundreds of accounts every
time it happens my team will
block it um or i'll block it personally
i'll see it'll block it in the middle of
the night oh
someone pretends for me i'll block them
or delete it but then they'll just set
up a new account and a new account new
car pretending to be made
so although um it is nice to be very
fired the biggest reason i'm happy is
because having a tick next to my name
means that when you see me comment in
the chat
my name samuel leeds will have a tick
next to it you'll know that it's the
real me
all the real samuel leads please have a
tick next to his name i actually feel as
well like they've studied how you
respond because i've read one once and i
was [ __ ] like oh
and it literally sounded like something
that samuel would say and then it was
like oh
that was a scam so yeah just yeah
we don't know what
i don't want people pretending to be me
and they're not me that's just strange
um
that just happened a lot just um sidebar
yeah on
on instagram people always pretend to be
samuel on instagram
and this one time someone actually
posted like
i can't remember what it said now but
they posted a picture of me in him
and they actually tagged me as in the
real amanda so there it was a fake
samuel profile but they tagged me as
like oh
my wife at amanda t leads and i was just
like i saw this tag and i was like
went on it and it was a profile of you
but then with lots of different pictures
of samuel but they'd actually tagged me
which was like
oh silly you'll know this fake because
if you if you see me on instagram with
like
12 followers um only three or four posts
on the account and then usually
they'll change it and say like oh forex
trading awesome it's just really random
like yeah and i do sometimes worry that
people will think that it's me and then
go into some business deal with them but
you'd have to be a little bit naive to
not realize but i think the the
verification tick now makes it all the
more
um you know makes it much better i can
relax
now so that's awesome all right so
that's basically what i've been doing
and i've been writing books
um obviously i've written i've written
my um
book which we spoke about in the last
podcast yes we did yeah success students
which thank you by the way guys that
absolutely blew up we had
um within the first week we had 2
of just over 2 000 downloads
um over 50 reviews so
thank you for downloading thank you for
reviewing
and drumroll i'm going to talk about it
on this video
but i am working on another book
thank you so i've been quietly working
on that do you want to
say what the book is about or do you
know i'm going to say nothing
in the comments what do you think it is
let me know in the comments so that's
that
so what i wanted to talk about on this
week's
episode is money management because i
think that one of the three one of the
first things that
when we got married that i actually
introduced to you if you're ready
tell me about what what happened with
the money management how we manage our
money but talk from the beginning like
do you remember when i first said this
is how because just for the record
i don't manage the money in our house
amanda manages the money i do
i do fully manages the money but i did
teach her the system to use to manage
money yeah
so go ahead yeah so um
when we first got married again this is
like a big thing if you
don't or if you don't know whatever but
you have to talk about money
before you get serious with anyone you
kind of have to be transparent about
that so
anyway um when we got married the
conversation was like okay
money what we gonna do and i
am a big spender so before i'd literally
get paid and i didn't really
save i would just spend my money like
shopping zara that sort of stuff so
that was like hmm and when i met you
you're a bit more of a saver
it's really more responsible yeah i feel
like we've switched roles
do you not feel that yeah actually
because i'm to be honest that's true
that's true
i'm sometimes like oh really and you're
like come on let's open
up such a special you're like an
extravagant spender
you don't spend small it's like big
space i used to be
i used to be so i feel like i feel like
we're not central to um
is there more space this side well i
think it's just because you're bigger
than me okay
i used to be before i met amanda
the biggest hoarder ever like i used to
i used to be
so frugal so tight
um i would i was earning well when we
first met
i didn't tell you about my properties no
because i was like i don't want to tell
people about my money
because then they might just you know
try and
you know pretend they like me but really
they just like the money so mandy didn't
know anything about my property business
and i would lived a reasonably frugal
life and when when we met
i was living in a two-bedroomed terrace
house
in blockswitch it was nice it was not
like a new building yeah
it was but it wasn't fancy we moved even
when we first moved to our house we
moved to a detached house but it's just
a three bedroom detectives
i do miss the house a little bit i love
that house our first house together
you know so i was really frugal um
and amanda was a little bit of a spender
i was i was nothing crazy though
you just like to go shopping and things
like that and i said to amanda listen
this is how i manage my money
and i taught her this process and i said
and this is how i would like to
introduce
do we manage money in our marriage this
was before we got married
yeah so i went through it amanda said
that sounds cool totally great
now i'm not involved in the slightest
what is the system the system is the
money management system so
we have um several bank accounts that we
have and then we
split them up so when we get paid we
have necessities
play give um
education education financial freedom
[Music]
um long-term savings long-term savings
so what that means is
when you get your paycheck and this is
the thing as well like before me and
amanda married
i was depending on how the month went
some months i learned really well oh man
things are going really really good but
then other months
if you had some problems with some
tenants things the money wasn't so good
so one of the things that i implemented
and i have to credit a guy called half
ecker because i learned this from him
initially back when i was like 19.
um but one of the things that i learned
is
number one you have to pay yourself a
wage so
if you're employed you're just you're
just on a wage
if you're self-employed you're not on a
wage if you're self-employed it's like
well
depending on how that month went depends
on how much you'll get but you need to
say no every month i'm going to pay
myself
out of my business this much money and
you and you're on a wage and then when
you get paid your wage
if you're employed already it's easy
because you're just told what your wage
is
when you pay your wage rather than
spending it all at once
what you have to do is you have to take
the money after let's say you get two
thousand pounds
you put that two thousand pounds into
six different bank accounts
so you're gonna put fifty percent of it
into necessities
and then you're gonna break it up you're
gonna put ten percent into your
education
funds 10 you're going to put to giving
giving away 10
into your investment fund
10 into your savings fund and 10
into your play phone my favorite fund
so what kind of things what kind of
things would you use your play money for
what kind of things would you buy with
play money okay so with play money i'd
spend on maybe like a nice bag
massages shopping for clothes just
whatever i feel like treating myself
with that that month so
you play money you have to spend it you
have to blow it
because when you usually because and
here's what this is so genius
she was a spender i was a saver but with
this money management system you've got
a certain amount of allocated money
that you have to blow yeah and it's no
questions like you won't ask me like oh
what do you spend your money on
just look whatever i want and you can
have separate play money you probably
should
we did we we did we still do but see so
so
for me at the time i was like when i
first started doing this i'm like man
i've got to spend the money geez
i want to i want to keep that i want to
put that into my investment fund it's
like no no
with this system you have to
blow the money now for amanda because
she was a spender for her it's like
yeah i want more i don't want to put
money into saving
i want to split but it's like no no you
have to blow it
but you can't buy more than 10 percent
and what that does is it means it gives
dis for people like amanda a
spender it gives discipline yeah well
people like me
who was a massive saver it
forces you to blow the money which means
that you begin to think a bit richer
because if you're living in poverty all
the time and
saving everything you need to live you
need to have some fun
and if we got married about that system
what would have happened is you would
have started to spend money
i would have been you don't want to
spend every penny i don't want to save
every penny but because of the
the system that we had it meant that
we've we have
never ever argued about money yeah and i
think that's like probably a big thing
that lots of couples argue about is
money
yeah and i think having this system in
place really really just
negates that it does we've never argued
about money
and ever and we've also i mean we've
grown
wealthy together i mean okay i was
already doing decent when we met but
when we met
i mean it was amanda's massively helped
with the business and we've blown up
but what's happened is i mean even now
our income we just pay ourselves a set
wage don't we yeah so we have a set wage
which comes from our property
company um and you know i obviously do
lots of other stuff you know
i've got loads of i'm training and
there's dinner stuff but we just have uh
just like really when we first got
married yeah it's not
massively different yeah you know but
what's happened is
because we're putting a percentage of
our money into our investment fund
our investment fund puts more money
which grows which means the percentages
are the same
but then it's like oh i used to have 200
pound or 300 pound a month to spend on
play money
now i have 500 pound a month now i have
10
you know and it grows um but yeah i mean
it's great and
you also never think it's sometimes
people say i couldn't live off 50
and then put the 10 10 10. it doesn't
matter what the percentages are it's
just about doing it isn't it yeah have
you found that
yeah yeah i think you can just it
changes as well like sometimes you might
want to
put save more in your um investment fund
or
i don't know put more into your play or
whatever it's just whatever
so you can do it as little or as much as
you're earning it doesn't really matter
also there's one guy who was paying
himself
um so he wasn't paying himself he was
employed and he was on he was earning
about 1200
a month and he was like i can't live up
to 600 pound a month for necessities and
i can't give 10 percent
i can't afford to give 10 i'll give 10
when i'm rich and it's like no yeah the
bible talks about this it says be
faithful with a little and then you'll
be given more
and i believe that whether you know
whether you're a christian or believe
the bible or not
the principle of being faithful with
what you've got
and then you'll be given more it's so so
true yeah um so
and in fact that guy he decided that he
couldn't quite do it as i taught
but what he did was he paid himself 90
for essentials and then he just split it
up he was like two percent is going to
be on
give i'll give two percent on invest two
percent and
slowly over the years he's now he's now
up to up to up and started learning more
so the key when you stop when you manage
what you've got
most people say i need more money i want
more money i want more money and it's
like
fine but when you just manage what
you've got
it's almost like if you've got a bucket
with holes in it and then you're going
to want more water or more water it's
like
just fix the holes yeah you know get the
capacity right and then
maybe you'll start getting more money so
i think money management is something
really important
why do you manage people might find it
strange that you manage the money in the
house
what does that look like how much
control of the money do you have and
what
what involvement do i have okay so i
have 100
control oh wow i'm the boss at home
and i think it's just because you can't
you focus on the business yeah
and then i focus on the household and
her so
it's just how we found what works for us
so
yeah it's just what we do yeah i mean
listen
in terms of oh i actually don't want i
can't be bothered i spend so much time
you know with the business like going
through deals and money and this and
that for me i'm just very happy to just
say
you know when it comes to when it comes
to home stuff i mean
i don't even like when we moved into
this house i hadn't even seen the house
so i don't know it was the previous one
when we
in litchfield yeah yeah i viewed the
house in litchfield
did the viewing this i'm sure this house
though maybe i saw it one time then i
don't remember but definitely the house
before the one we lived in
you totally trust me with anything home
home wise absolutely
you know absolutely so um you know what
advice would you give to somebody
that was wanting to get a grip of their
finances
i'd say definitely try out this money
magic management system for starters
yeah and this money management system
bother this is how all wealthy people do
manage their money
um if you read the book called the
richest man in babylon
it talks about very similar principles
um i'd recommend reading
uh secrets of the millionaire minds by
harvecker it talks about very very well
not similar like
it's pretty much the same also even in
the bible like joseph
remember the story when joseph um was
asked to be pretty prince of egypt and
he recommended he said look when you get
your
at the time egypt was booming at the
time and it was like there was
loads of money loads of wealth and the
crops were boo
and he said look um although
everything's booming now
he said what you need to do is you need
to put a seventh of everything just
put it aside yeah a seventh of
everything and then we're like oh we
don't need to do that and he said no do
it
so so egypt would put a seventh of all
its resources aside
and then when the big recessions came
the economic collapse happens and
everything everything started all drying
up
egypt was became one of the most
powerful countries in the world
because it it it it put money aside so
it goes back to this whole
um idea of pay yourself first you know
what pay yourself first means is
rather than when you get paid saying
oh i need to pay for my gas and electric
and i just put my taxes by this i need
to spend my landlord when i spend my
mortgage
and then i'll invest what's left it's
like no
when you get paid just put a little
portion aside put it aside for
you for your financial security
for your investment fund before anyone
else can touch it
put it aside invest it in property put a
portion aside for you
for your education we put a lot of money
inside for our education that personal
growth that personal development
one of the reasons that we've probably
not argued about money and had a lot of
issues a lot of people
have generally in life is because we're
always investing in ourselves bettering
ourselves
invest in you before investing in other
stuff
and then of course what's left 50 put
that in
to your general so i think you know it's
a really really really important lesson
yeah um okay so last week we asked for
questions we said if you've got
questions comment below
no one really did um so no one
everyone's watching the video this is
the opportunity to put questions in now
most popular video but no one's asking
questions
for us and no one is coming up with a
name
for the podcast that's he couldn't get
the podcast because at some point amanda
is going to
upload the the audio of this onto a
podcast on spotify and yeah
i don't know what they're called but
before she does that she wants to know
yeah i want a name so i can make a nice
little logo and stuff because i like to
be organized so i've come up with some
questions which i haven't preempted
amanda for in fact if you have any
questions for me amanda
no i don't all right question for you
right now we are in spring
yeah coming close to summer which or
which um
season do you prefer and why spring
or autumn how come it has to be between
those two
because otherwise it will be summer
every time and
someone's the winner winter's the loser
we know that we know that already
yeah yeah but the two in the middle
autumn and okay i would probably say
i like ah it's hard but i probably go
for autumn oh
why only because it's like the leaves
are falling
it's pretty i like being able to wear a
dress still with tights it's like you
just
layering layering up whereas right now
when it springs sometimes it looks like
it's really warm outside
you go outside in a dress and it's too
cold and it's like oh you don't really
know should i wear it should i wear a
coat she'll wear a cardigan
but in autumn you can still wear dresses
but then you can just like wear tights
and you know it's a bit of a safe bet
in the amanda's whole choice of which is
the best season is all
around her clothes and her dresses
um all right for me i would say spring
because spring
there's more hope in spring because
spring is like summer's coming on the
way
it's awesome it's nice but it's like
winter's coming
yeah yeah deep yeah
i mean yeah deep deep next question then
okay even deeper question than that oh
dear go away would you rather would you
roll the
would you rather only be able to shower
once every seven days or
have to shower seven times every day
i would probably shower every seven
hours
no that wasn't i didn't say every seven
hours oh every hour for seven days
no go on seven showers a day
yep or one shower every seven days
seven showers a day scent really yeah
hold on just think about this though
okay go on if you only have a shower
once a week obviously that's horrible
you can use deodorant you can rub
yourself whatever
it wouldn't be great be horrible but
having to shower
seven times a day it would be a bit
would mean you wouldn't be able to
go anywhere you're meant to leave the
house the permanent lockdown you're
showering all the time your skin would
probably stop peeling
okay yeah but it would just be like be a
bit gross
wouldn't it like showering once a week
more sales question
what was the last book that you read
both fiction
and non-fiction okay so my
last non-fiction book no my last fiction
book was probably when we last went on
holiday
that's the only time we read it was
called the paul house oh yeah yeah
and it was nice it was just like a
little drama a bit of murder
mystery that sort of thing yeah it was
cool and i like reading those kind of
books
when we're on holiday because i feel
like it's just the only time that you
can just
relax and be like huh if i'm reading and
i'm at home
i feel like reading a fiction book is a
bit wasteful
i can't read fiction books yeah i don't
hate them
okay i just haven't got the inclination
to read them
for me i love reading but reading is
effort
for me from reading it's effort like if
i'm watching a movie
it's like it's passive reading is energy
it's effort
if i'm taking the effort to read i want
to read something where i'm going to be
learning
and i'm going to be better and you know
what i think that yeah that's rubbed off
on me a bit because
for that reason i only read fiction
books novels when we're on holiday
because i just kind of last book you
read that was
it was non-fiction okay um it was
the millionaire next door i don't like
that book
yeah you don't but something that i
thought was quite good from it okay
first of all
it actually was interesting for me
because a lot of things that you did
when we met
true were i was like oh my gosh that's
like samuel i feel like that
is sort of in you the fact that you are
living so frugally
yeah so there's lots of things in there
that i see in you that oh my goodness
yeah so interesting that you do
naturally maybe i do like the book after
all
but um something else as well that i
found really interesting in it was about
kids because samuel's always been like
oh i don't want to spoil the kids and i
kind of thought i had been a bit harsh
before we've had kids we'll talk about
that in another podcast oh yeah we'll
talk about it
and um but yeah just the fact that
people that are millionaires or wealthy
people
don't spoil the kids and i thought that
was quite interesting reading that in
the book and
yeah and maybe maybe i should reread it
the millionaire next door is very much
about living frugally
yeah and all that and it was actually
grant cardone who said um i don't want
to be the millionaire next door
because he's like yes who wants to be
the millionaire next door the person is
a millionaire but lives really frugally
you wouldn't even know forget that i
want to i want to i want to be the
billionaire
on tv not the millionaire next door
you know but yeah i guess those things
have got us to where we are now
maybe maybe my last book that i read
that was i don't read fiction at all my
last non-fiction
was the book that i wrote with the help
of some of my friends my students
which was my success books is it sad
that the last
two books that i've read my books i
don't think it's sad i mean it's quite
cool but i mean it's like
the last book i read before that was
purpose-driven life
uh yeah which is really good but again
it's more of a devotional
so all right cool so what should the
podcast be called comment below
questions for me amanda so why don't i
have to think of
crazy questions about showering it would
be great to hear
yeah would you rather questions be great
to hear from you what questions
and and final words of wisdom you always
ask me this and it
catches me off guard every single day
why don't you just prepare
i have a question i don't know you're
gonna ask me every single time
all right just for the record so it's on
camera so you can't say that no
every time we end the podcast i'm gonna
say i'm gonna find a word okay it's
gonna be mandy's worth of wisdom at the
end of every single one
but what's your words of wisdom there
was wisdom now should be always prepared
always be prepared
all right guys subscribe see you next
time thanks for watching peace out
bye
[Music]